these are your best friends so close
that they're practically family
or should I say literally just like your
family every squad has the child not
necessarily the youngest in age but
definitely in spirit the child runs on
the power of positivity without ever
running out of something to say I've
done this thing as much as I love fried
chicken I love hanging with you guys you
know what I think we're ready to order
okay what can I get you guys hello what
is your name remember Kevin right yes
welcome no the child also has the
uncanny ability to turn any stranger
however strange into a new friend so can
I get anyone something to drink oh you
know actually a seltzer would be nice
Keith you're getting the remote all
three seeds hand it over
we're gonna decide what to watch as a
group and just like a baby sometimes
lacks the ability to fully control his
own winds look that dudes just like a
baby yeah it's like you've lacks the
ability to fully control his own limbs
protect the child at all costs because
he's the most fun and sweet friend
you'll ever have then there's the adult
of the group the one who's stuck in peak
mom and dad mode 24/7 love guards the
adults parental advisory instincts kick
into high gear whenever a resolution
needs to be reached last time so we're
gonna go with Zac's choice goody
the [ __ ] what about me you know your
show super depressing and not
appropriate for Keith which one's the
search button what
draw on your snapchats that's your
Instagram story and no instagrams per
picture and like many a parent the
ever-changing social media landscape is
never immediately apparent to the adult
yes I come another punchy rock guy catch
me out ha how about bad everything oh
excuse me we're ready to order
I'd like the ahi tuna salad and this guy
will get fried chicken combo and who
cares if you're a little behind the
times when you're the only one on top of
yours I have several questions about
several of the items so you all know and
hope to survive the teenager the friend
in your group who is awfully good at
being awesome ly bad someone take this
from me my body is gonna good morning
thank you all that dude's body's gonna
regret it
his little Benjamin Button body hahahaha
my [ __ ] the teenager is violent and
unpredictable to come to your defense
Kevin how are you who's Kevin let's face
it on the outside the teenager can be a
shady [ __ ] in your sleep but on the
inside the teenager is a profoundly
sensitive friend that's dead and that's
Zach and I don't know where Eugene well
happy birthday buddy
Oh oh my god a pepper shaker I've always
wanted one of these you're still left
from Kevin who's Kevin is anyone else
freezing am I crazy they just turn every
time I sit underneath event they turn on
the bend and it's like and finally
everyone knows the old person who's
stuck in oh can you not freeze frame on
my face we get it on the grumpy old man
those were kind of too far in the video
right now we get it we can move can you
get this out of here what do you do okay
well as I was saying the old person I
know I've evolved law you are so boring
can we come to the apartment it's cold
in here
no one else thinks it's really hot in
here am I ever crazy hey Carl
can you dump whatever go to the
thermostat turn it down like hey excuse
me it's my job to Neri strong please
yeah why is everyone so incompetent
I'm sorry really Hey ladies excuse me up
my moody friend here with the spiky hair
he wants to appoint one of you I'm not
sure who maybe I'm deaf I don't know
anyway I'm going to hand my friend a
present we can end the video no need for
fancy editing
cat dammit
okay just just make it quick perfect and
that is how your friends are literally
just like your family quick quick roll
the credits before I die
oh and squad wars at the show that we
made thanks so much for watching please
check out our new YouTube retro squad
Wars this week we have Rebecca Black and
Jessica Marie Garcia going head-to-head
against million dollar listing stars in
a Bollywood challenge watch it for us
won't you
I [ __ ] hate smiling you know cuz
we're a squad and then we make other
squads do stuff if you like this you
should watch that if you didn't like
this well you watch the whole thing so
joke's on you they turn the air
conditioning on again oh my god it is
freezing in here oh look there's the if
you didn't know yet you're watching a
BuzzFeed video really really get it in
your face with that branding when use
another BuzzFeed bang really terrible
sound actually oh can we do that again
without the sounds it's really grating
ah that's so much better
[Music]